if you are just one of those players
you've never played on a competitive
team before you've always just played so
low-key you've played ladder and you're
like hey I'm really good League of
Legends how do I get a chance to play on
a pro team
well if you're asking how you get to pro
a lot of people are gonna say Academy
nine Academy will be your 2018 North
American Academy League champion
three-fifths of the Rakata me roster got
promoted for day one here this is kind
of what the Academy system was made for
if they smash on stage they could
solidify their spot on the starting rust
today professional gaming is an
aspiration shared by thousands of gamers
and enjoyed by millions of fans but pro
gaming wasn't always a viable career as
eSports have grown over the years so has
the infrastructure but even with the
advent of Riots own League of Legends
Championship Series the path to becoming
pro still wasn't clear so riot built the
academy League with the goal of
cultivating the next generation of LCS
talent today we're taking a look at the
path to pro for League of Legends fans
who want to climb their way to the top
before this year it was LCS and
Challenger and there was a huge gap
between those two I think I think the
Challenger Series and the LCS team was a
joke generally in the sense that like
the LCS players never saw the Academy
players as any kind of serious
competition they just existed as a lower
league challenger series was essentially
new teams were put together with the
sole goal of this is how you get into
LCS as a team the bottom teams from LCS
would be put in a spot where they had to
fight for their spot in LCS against the
top teams from challenger it was called
the promotion relegation tournament now
in the franchising era there is no more
promotion to relegation we have ten
permanent teams in the LCS Academy
League teams became tied to the LCS
teams it'd almost be like you know your
varsity team and your JV team because at
the end of the Year bottleless JV
players can be brought up to the main
squad if you're looking for a little bit
more power a little bit of diversity in
the play it's very much in a system
where you can say hey we want X
academies big purpose should be to find
these players in North America and bring
them up the joke the twitch chat always
likes to use is na teams aren't even
made of na players because we have so
many imports from EU and so many imports
from Korea and all these other things
what Academy allows you to do is take
home grown in a talent and foster that
talent and build it up to the point
where they can compete we've seen a lot
of these players really improve quickly
really get ready to go Azazel brought
into cloud nine I think of JJ on fly
quest throughout high school I knew this
was something I wanted to pursue but it
was just like a faraway dream in the
distance that I never really thought
would actually happen I played for the
University of Toronto caleda team we
played in the
North American college championship
where we play second that took us to
international collegiate tournaments and
so fly class decided to pick us up for
their Academy team our coach would help
us focus on what we each wanted to
improve on I wanted to have higher game
knowledge and higher level of
shotcalling so that's what he helped me
with and that's what helped me move up
from Academy tell CS fly quest LCS team
was predicted to be ninth place 10th
place somewhere around the bottom by a
lot of people and then they show up they
win against a bunch of the top teams
that nobody thought they stood a
snowball's chance against and they end
up making it into playoffs and that's
what I think again makes it so cool when
you look at a story like JJ's cuz this
isn't a player who came in and went from
collegiate success to academy success to
bottom of the barrel LCS 9th or 10th
place this is a player who went from
collegiate success to academy success to
playoffs in a split where nobody thought
his team should be in playoffs and
that's awesome that's success while JJ's
story is an ideal scenario of moving
from fan to pro the Academy also has a
larger effect on the LCS I like the
teams are rostering 10 players that if
someone's sick they've got a mid laner
ready to go out of the box I think
that's really really useful if someone's
not playing very well they're
unmotivated or for some reason the game
just really doesn't suit them they're
having a really really bad month you've
got someone ready to go to kind of
promote up being able to work with the
Academy guys and help them improve in
the hopes that they can make a name for
themselves they can have an LCS career
is great because I know that I was like
once in those shoes myself and I wanted
to like prove myself and move my way up
I think there's a lot of opportunities
for mentorship some teams have weird
dynamics who are like they're more
competitive but on our team I found it
to be pretty healthy for a lot of our
players like impact is our top laner for
LCS and our Academy top laner is Viper
and both of them just bounce ideas off
each other all the time if you are one
of the bottom teams in the North
American LCS and you're not looking at
Academy as a potential place to find new
talent grow your organization better
your roster and increase your chances of
being one of the best teams in the
future I think you're missing an
opportunity I think right now the
Academy players are all
actual LCS players it's not borderline
LCS players teams like c9 are using
cavity players very well c9 yeah they
were doing poorly even in scrims like
their Academy team was outperforming
their LCS team so they got a shot and
then for the first couple of weeks they
just mixed up the roster and then they
worked out really well for them c9 with
an incredible run this year you may have
noticed a recent influx of traditional
sports teams and athletes investing in
the world of competitive gaming tune in
next week as we talk to team owners and
players about how the business of
eSports is changing
[Music]